[Music]
a guide to grammar the infographics
[Music]
introduction
english is a challenging language to
master even for native speakers
why well for starters
it's been spiced by many dialects and
regional variations
[Music]
adjectives
an adjective modifies a noun or a
pronoun to give more information about a
person place or think verbs
a verb is a word that indicates an
action or a state of being
it tells the story of the sentence
[Music]
a verb tenses
verb tenses relate action to time
telling us whether something has
occurred in the past is happening right
now or will take place in the future
regular versus irregular verbs
exceptions to the rule as if learning
about tenses wasn't complicated enough
the english language stumps learners
with irregular verbs in fact some of our
most common verbs
are irregular pronouns a pronoun is a
word that takes the place of a noun to
add variety and avoid a repetition
prepositions and prepositional phrases
as you can see from the infographic
these are also known as linking words
a preposition connects a noun or a
pronoun to another word in the sentence
to show the relationship between the two
conjunctions or connectors
think of conjunctions as words that join
two parts of a sentence together
interjections
expressing emotion
what really you need help on
interjections
no way
sentence functions a sentence is made up
of one or more words and expresses a
complete thought in a statement question
request command or
exclamation subject and predicates
major parts of a sentence
sentences can be very short or very long
at a minimum though they must contain a
subject and a predicate how do we make
smooth sentences subject verb agreement
there is only one rule about
subject-verb agreement you must make
verbs agree with their subject in number
and in person of course this is english
so this rule can be tricky to follow
compound subjects compound subjects
consist of two or more individual nouns
or noun phrases connected by and or or
to form a single longer noun phrase
complements
making sense we have five kinds of
compliments
while some sentences contain only a
subject and a verb others use more words
to make things clearer tell a story or
ask a question these additional sentence
components are called complements
phrases a phrase is a group of words
that adds detail to a sentence but
doesn't have a subject and a verb
phrases can be part of sentences but
cannot stand alone adding detail we have
five types of phrases clauses
a clause is a phrase with a subject and
a verb and any complements that verb
requires
depending on the type it may or may not
be able to stand alone as a sentence we
have different kind of clauses
we'll get into that later
restrictive clauses and non-restrictive
clauses categorizing clauses is not easy
clauses can also be categorized by
whether or not they are necessary to the
meaning of a sentence after all
sometimes we need more detail and
sometimes we don't
whereas non-restrictive clauses could be
omitted from a sentence without changing
its meaning parallelism and logical
sentences
sometimes you must organize related
thoughts show that actions are
sequential or build to a climax and make
a point these cases call for parallelism
which means using the same grammatical
structure for all the similar parts of a
sentence capitalization using upper case
when you capitalize you write a word
with the first letter in uppercase and
the remaining letters in lowercase
ending a sentence when ending a sentence
you have three choices a period a
question mark or an exclamation point
use a period when your sentence states a
fact or makes a command
apostrophes and contractions the
apostrophe can cause confusion but it
doesn't have to three basic situations
require an apostrophe making a
contraction indicating possession or
forming a plural case
commas
creating a pause the comma creates a
slight pause in a sentence and helps
readers understand how items relate to
one another
quotation marks show which words are
yours and which belong to someone else
direct quotations most commonly
quotation marks show readers the exact
word someone said in the exact order
they were said
collins and sami collins
proper punctuation is very important
semicolon indicates a pause that is more
significant than a comma but less
significant than a period but most often
they connect two complete thoughts that
could be two separate sentences hyphens
m dashes and n dashes
word dividers hyphens and dashes
separate words and thoughts
a hyphen is shorter while n and m dashes
are longer parenthesis set off extra
information material that may not be
necessary but can be helpful
we use parentheses to set off a part of
a sentence
for dates series political affiliation
and alternate endings brackets square
brackets are most commonly found in
dictionaries where they enclose the
history of the word being defined other
than this usage there are a few key
places where you'll find them
parentheses and brackets always come in
pairs with an opening mark and a closing
mark bold italics and underlining all
emphasize words although you should use
these elements sparingly here's when to
use them in titles the names of movies
books poem collections plays oprah's tv
shows works of art magazines newspapers
ships
ellipsis an ellipsis is a punctuation
mark comprising three dots or periods
with no space between them ellipses have
two main functions to signal word
emission from a quoted passage or to
express mood
[Music]
the slash has four main uses in writing
one separates portions of the address in
a url two stands in for or
as in students may bring their mother
slash fathers to the open house
[Music]
abbreviations and acronyms an
abbreviation is a series of letters that
serves as a shortened version of a
longer word you still read or speak the
full word an acronym is a new word
formed by the initial letters of the
word it comprises identifying your
purpose and audience content and
connection knowing your specific
audience will guide what you write and
the words you use one determine and
purpose two identify your audience three
consider content four decide on
definitions five create connection and
six call to action active and passive
voice sentences with action verbs and
direct objects can be written in active
voice or passive voice understand the
difference between the two
[Music]
transitions making writing sound natural
we use these to show sequence or explain
steps to indicate cause and effect to
compare the contracts to show addition
or emphasis to indicate time to
generalize to show place paragraph
structure i'm guessing this is one of
the most boring classes you've ever had
in english a paragraph is a group of
sentences united by a single topic or
point knowing how to construct a
paragraph will help you write coherently
and persuasively fixing repetition and
introducing variety
making writing sparkle clarity is
important in writing but so is variety
keep your readers interested by avoiding
repetition in sentence length and word
choice foreign words and phrases english
is a language of borrowed words with
influences from german french and many
other tongues when using foreign words
and phrases how do you write them
improving writing there are four tips to
improve our writing like any skill your
writing ability improves over time with
practice here are a few tips that can
help
[Music]
cliches generalizations platitudes and
shotgun words of caution tips of
avoiding these traps there's much magic
in knowing the right words to use as in
knowing which ones to avoid
[Music]
commonly confused words
learn the difference to avoid mistakes
homophones are pronounced the same way
but have very different meanings for
example i and i even native english
speakers struggle with some words and
expressions
who and whom
which pronoun if you struggle to decide
whether to use who or whom in writing
and speech just remember who is always
the subject of the verb in the sentence
while whom is the object
more common mistakes these words can
also cause confusion
[Music]
commonly misused phrases
language traps confusing phrases knowing
the proper phrase and its spelling can
go a long way toward improving your
communication whether it's professional
or personal
modifier problems in the wrong place at
the wrong time when you're using
modifiers the words should be as close
as possible to whatever they describe or
elaborate on otherwise mistakes can
happen run on sentences and wordiness
too many words
trust me i know exactly what you're
saying contrary to their name rhino
sentences aren't necessarily long
fuzzy grammar
when accuracy counts throughout life
you'll encounter situations in which
total grammatical accuracy
is in your best interest
these instances include formal writing
assignments such as school papers
exams and published work and other
high-stakes situations such as cover
letters and job applications